bonjour à toutes et à tous aujourd'hui
nous allons parler un peu des glaciers
vous savez c'est très gros glaçon qui
recouvre des continents entiers pour une
surface équivalente à 30 fois la france
tout de suite ça jette un froid
[Musique]
ces glaciers sont confrontés au
réchauffement climatique qui affecte la
température des courants marins et de
l'air notamment sous l'effet des
tristement célèbres gaz à effet de serre
- moi je sens pas une si grande
différence de température poussant à bas
quand même attend l'année dernière en
arctique
il faisait 4,7 degrés plus chaud que ce
qu'on avait observé en moyenne pour la
fin du xxème siècle du coup les glaciers
fondent à grande vitesse gnagnagna les
ours polaires conclut banques qu'ils ben
moi temps qui me reste des glaçons dans
mon char de neige veut rien savoir
ouais le souci c'est qu'on voit arriver
de sérieux ennuis à cause de la fonte
des glaces et en premier lieu la montée
des eaux
rendez vous compte qu'en france les
côtes sableuses de la nouvelle aquitaine
recul jusqu'à 2 mètres par an d'ici 2050
la mère pourrait avoir gagné 50 m sur la
terre de quoi faire barboter le phare
des baleines sur l'île de ré ah non un
talent il donnait à temps où je vais
passer mes vacances moi bon c'est acquis
qu'il faut donner du pognon pour sauver
la banquise les autres polaire tout ça
on s'en sortira pas avec des actions
ponctuelles pour mieux lutter contre le
phénomène
il faut l'appréhender en profondeur pour
cela direction 200 mètres sous terre
sous le glacier d'argentière près de
chamonix ce géant de 19 kilomètres
carrés père en mètre d'épaisseur chaque
année depuis 30 ans nous sommes dans un
souterrain arpentés par une équipe de
chercheurs du cnrs pas comme les autres
des glaciologues beau facile un mot si
je suis glaciologue je connais tous les
parfums chocolat noix de macadamia mais
non la glaciologie c'est la science des
glaciers et ce devant de spécialistes
d'être très au fait des propriétés
physiques de la glace pour comprendre
comment elles se forment et se
transforme mais ça exige aussi d'être un
très bon topographe pour mesurer les
mouvements du glacier parce qu'il faut
pas croire mais les glaciers ça bouge
beaucoup
rendez vous compte que la vitesse de
déplacement des glaciers alpins est de
l'ordre de 40 m par an
comment le sait-on grâce à une
bicyclette vous voyez cette roue de vélo
elle tourne depuis 1900
112 le professeur robert vise y en a eu
l'idée de l'installer sous le glacier
pour mesurer comment ils se déplacent à
l'horizontale et à la verticale
toute la journée et toute l'année depuis
plus de 30 ans la roue cours sur le
glacier suivant le moindre de ses
frémissements et répercutant les
déplacements le long d'un bras qui on
voit toutes les informations dans un cas
vitaux mettre une roue en contact avec
la glace que capitaux m enregistre que
le glissement du blige et le lire aux
cheveux et les mouvements verticaux de
la boule au bo
fazila moi aussi je sus que vito m là je
rentre en voiture
là je rentre à vélo et là je rentre pas
les chercheurs ont aussi posé caméra
pour visualiser le mouvement du glacier
vu de dessous et quand on accélère
l'image le résultat est assez
impressionnant
vous trouvez ça badass vous n'avez
encore rien vu
le glacier d'argentière est le seul
gracier au monde à être sur écoute
le tout grâce à une mission digne de
james bond
baptisée horizon
m
donc ça à faire de maître un glacis sur
écoute sifac qovu un glacier et ben oui
en quelque sorte en se déplaçant sur le
sol rocheux le glacier et mais un
bruissement et en l'enregistrant les
chercheurs vont pouvoir comprendre à
quelle vitesse et selon quelles
dynamiques le glacier se déplace pour
cela 12 capteurs sismiques ont été
installés à la base du glacier
ils ont enregistré non-stop toutes les
vibrations pendant un mois les douze
capteurs souterrains sont accompagnés
200 capteurs disposés en surface à 2500
mètres d'altitude s'il vous plaît et il
vaut mieux être prêt à mouiller la combi
de ski parce que deux heures d'ascension
seront nécessaires pour atteindre le
haut du glacier en surface un capteur
est posé tous les 50 mètres pour créer
un maillage de mouchard assez dense pour
créer une référence donc perçu les
chercheurs ont apporté un drôle d'objet
regardez cette lourde cloche ça va
alors l'autre depuis que je fais de la
scion selon elle permet de créer des
sources sismique artificielle en tapant
dessus et en enregistrant à intervalles
réguliers
les chercheurs se dote de points de
repère en observant les courbes créé par
les gangs sur les relevés sismiques
la conclusion de tout cette étude c'est
que ce glacier glisse de moins en moins
vite avec le temps ce qui n'est pas une
très bonne nouvelle parce que sid
ralenti c'est parce qu'il est mon lourd
parce qu'ils font logique alors comment
éviter d'essuyer un naufrage à la mode
titanic mais sans l'iceberg
vu que il leur a fondu dans les
prochaines décennies
et bien tout d'abord nous devons
poursuivre nos efforts pour réduire la
production de gaz à effet de serre grâce
à nos gestes écologiques quotidien
mais il nous faudra sans doute aussi
rendre les zones littorales plus sûr
grâce à divers aménagements
architecturaux comme les digues par
exemple permettant de réduire l'avancé
de la mer vers nos habitations
sinon après les masques on risque d'être
obligé de porter des bottes chez nous et
ça c'est pas terrible
voilà c'est tout pour cette épisode un
peu glaçant mais on vous dis à très
bientôt pour un prochain épisode d'un
geste pour la planète et d'ici là
offrez-nous du like du partage et
surtout abonnez vous là je rentre un
vélo là non c'est l'horreur